طبعا التعامل مع الحالات في في هذا الملف
هي مساله صعبه جدا كل طفل هو حاله مستقله
خاصه بحدها وتحتاج الى تعامل بشكل
استثنائي وبالتالي تم التعامل مع كل حاله
بشكل منفرد حتى الوصول الى المعلومات
الصحيحه حول لم شمل هؤلاء
الاطفال بذويهم ومن ثم طبعا تم الحصول على
موافقه العائلات المعنيه لان تتم العمليه
بهذا الش وثم بالتنسيق مع المؤسسات
الانسانيه المختلفه ومع الطرفين الروسي
والاوكراني تم لم شمل هذه العائلات في
السفاره القطريه حيث استقبلهم
الدبلوماسيون القطريون وحيث بقوا هناك
لفتره لضمان طبعا ان تتم هذه المساله
بالشكل المناسب ومن ثم اصطحبهم
الدبلوماسيون القطريون الى وجهاتهم
النهائيه في استونيا او في دول اوروبا
الشرقيه المختلفه والان طبعا هذا يعني
بمثابه اذا صح التعبير مقدمه لمزيد من
العمل في هذا الاطار في محاوله طبعا لم
شمل عدد اكبر من من الاطفال وهناك ترحيب
من الجانبين بهذه المساله وقطر مستمره في
هذا الامر بحيث ان تنجز اكبر قدر ممكن
ونرى مثل هذه الصور المفرحه تتكرر